deux par deux les passagers du costa
magica font vérifier leur température
une vérification comme la chine
notamment en pratique depuis un mois
pour limiter la propagation du
coronavirus italien martiniquais ou
canadiens les voyageurs se prête aux
tests s'assurer qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas
attrapé le virus
le fameux virus qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est une bonne chose absolument c'est
la fin d'un épisode de 24 heures qui a
vu le navire de croisière manqué
l'escale de sainte lucie selon le
gouvernement saint lucien le capitaine
aurait refusé les conditions imposées
par les autorités
laisser certains passagers à bord en
fonction de leur provenance
une situation qui a levé la peur de voir
des patients atteints du fameux virus y
compris à bord par ce qui me concerne
j'ai passé une journée tranquille après
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont un
peu
cain une petite scie cause je dirais
puisque il ne savait pas trop ce qui se
passait pour ils étaient bloqués parce
que il y avait des cas sur le bateau
alors que c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
un malade avait été signalée le médecin
de la rs est monté à bord ce matin c'est
un monsieur qui est malade connu qui
descend en guadeloupe et qui est un
malade connu depuis des années donc il a
fait une chute
conick donc on n'a pas de problème par
rapport à ça et nous n'avons pas
d'autres signes d' alerte au moment où
je vous parle nous n'avons pas d'autre
s'il a l'air pour le bac et le
débarquement a pu avoir lieu malgré la
présence d'un groupe de manifestants
devant les grilles à 600 passagers
italiens se trouve sur le navire
l'italie compte aujourd'hui plus de 500
cas mais sur une population de 60
millions d'habitants alors les passagers
italiens ne sont pas spécialement
inquiet in italy les journalistes on
écrit beaucoup trop beau trop vous
pensez qu'on a exagéré le problème et
nous sommes les unter den le monde sait
qu'on vous a stigmatisé il ya moins de
problèmes ici
je pense entre demain et samedi
quatre autres navires de croisière sont
attendus en martinique le même
dispositif devrait être mis en place